How are you going to deal with a question of heterogeneity? Some approaches
include standard APIs. Those standards come from organizations like W3C,
that is the World Wide Web Consortium, OMG the Object Management Group which is
the promogater of GML, ANSI American National Standards Institute,
international standards organization. All of these standard API's and
protocols must at least address the issue of backward and forward compatibility.
Backwards compatibility means if you've got a new version, does that
version support or break older versions. Tougher is forward compatibility.
In your current version, are you promising that regardless of how the particular
standard may change in the future, that the current version will be supported.
Second is the question of normative architectures.
Here OMG is taking a stab with what they call Model-Driven Architecture, MDA,
in which the parts of a systems architecture which are machine independent
are separated from the machine dependent parts. And then there is
a co-generation process that enables the generation of the dependent parts from
some kinds of machine descriptions. The major vendors or
players in the game also offer there own ways of dealing with heterogeneity. For
example, Sony has its what originally was called J2E and is now called JEE.
Microsoft has .Net, IBM has Websphere and so on.